I can't quit you Brian when Horst every
time I think the off season has arrived
I pull back then shouldn't it be all
football talk on the show right now you
leaving me alone to have lunch with my
wife
I appreciate you put the win Horst love
affair on hold for just a few moments to
call in so when when did this happen
when did Kyrie say I want out
July 7th didn't get out for two weeks
which is a remarkable thing in today's
NBA OTT I also think that it shows that
the Cavs weren't really engaging in
trade talks because something this big I
wouldn't say we would always get it but
what a player this big is available on
the trade market usually those of us who
specialize in this find out and we
didn't find out it took and took two
weeks so you know you played that little
thing with that kid from from years ago
the Kyrie said that I don't need to play
pull out a quota and do gotcha with
Kyrie from from four or five seven years
ago one month ago during the final then
maybe six weeks at this point he was
talking about the balance that he has to
go through about whether he wants to be
the centerpiece of a team you know he
even used the word being selfish and
being the number one player on the team
or play alongside a great player in
LeBron and go for your team greatness he
even said he would rather be on a great
team as opposed to being up at 3:00 in
the morning wondering what the future of
his team was going to be so in the past
I was always aware that Kyrie did want
to have more of an independent situation
he his idol is Kobe Bryant he talked
about how he would go into his Mamba
mentality and mother mentality would be
have your own team but when when Kyrie
said that a month ago I thought you know
he's going to stick this out and wait
for this situation to LeBron to end
whether it would the end in 2018 or 19
or 20 and then go full mamba mentality
so I'm surprised I'm not surprised the
Kyrie wants out I mean it looked rich
there was a time where you left a
high-profile job for another
high-profile job right I mean and some
people probably thought you were crazy
for doing that and you've gone on to be
successful
so I'm not going to look down at kairi
kairi has every right to want to do this
I am surprised about the timing because
yes there are side effects the plan with
LeBron does he blame you when he makes a
mistake defensively yeah to see some
tweet and passive-aggressive you on
social media yes does he have the team
for the bend around his desires with
travel and schedule and stuff like that
yes - across the board is it worth it
just about everybody he's ever played
with or played for would say yes so this
is unusual but certainly we'll see how
Kyrie does in the long term on so then
let's hit the third rail on the on the
reading in between the lines of the
piece Brian did LeBron do anything to
bring up to the fore or to put it in a
spot for Kyrie that he just couldn't
take anymore sharing the stage with
LeBron it's a wonderful question for
Kyrie I I can explain his thought
process because I'm aware of it because
he's spoken about it before I can
explain his motivation because of his
affinity for how Kobe Bryant operates I
can't explain the timing that's a
question that Tyrese would have to
answer and again a month and a half ago
he was talking about how this
arrangement and he even used even said
this era he talked about how it was
important to play for the team in this
era and when he said all that I I was
under the impression that he was going
to continue to suppress what he wanted
to continue to say with his team so I
just I don't understand the timing I
don't know if something happened between
then and now or if he was just saying
something the media that wasn't true
which is not against the law or what but
obviously that's a great question I
don't know the answer that one Brian
when Horst of ESPN again part of the
crew that brought broke the news over
the weekend that Kyrie Irving has asked
to get out of Cleveland
what does Cleveland do right now well
they got three choices rich one is they
don't have to trade them because you've
got two years left on his contract go
back to Kobe with the Lakers in 2007 I
can still remember my then co-worker Ric
Bucher going on
Kobe Bryant will never play another game
in a Laker uniform like oh he demanded
the trade but the Lakers had him under
contract for years they they worked
through it and he has appointed two more
championships that's one option option
number two is they can look to trade for
young pieces and drafting this is what
typically happens when a star gets
traded the team rebuild and attempts to
you know get to you know better for the
long term look at what the Bulls just
did with Jimmy Butler solar situation
two years on his contract they got two
prospects in the top seven draft sticks
or they could trade for veterans and
this is what is a little bit more
difficult because the Cavs have LeBron
on the last year of a deal it's not like
Nepal Georgia Jimmy Butler trades or
Indiana and Chicago are taking a step
back
the Cavs don't want to take a step back
but yet they have the hot potato of
LeBron free agency that they have to
plan for either direction so it's going
to take some time and that's why I'm not
surprised that two weeks passed and this
didn't get out because I think the
calves are studying trying to figure out
what their move is going to be and not
wanting to go fast with this very
important decision and then Brian this
story would have just been huge on its
own and then toss in the fact that the
Cavs had Paul George basically on the
team in a uniform that they would have
been the ones to win the Paul George if
you will lottery by trading for him in a
three-way deal that would have sent
Kevin Love to to Denver so I asked you
the question I asked rhetorically before
you joined in the segment before and
that is if Paul George had come would
Kyrie have wanted out saying that he
didn't want to play with LeBron anymore
so here's all here's I can't say what I
will you know you know hypothetical but
here's what I can say the cab's really
thought they were about to trade for
Paul George for Kevin Love
the Pacers never thought they were going
to agree to that deal the Pacers would
have traded Paul George to the Cavs for
Kyrie Irving but the Cavs didn't feel
the need to offer the felt that they had
to trade Kyrie Irving back then those
are things I can say with confidence you
know I think there's another possibility
what if the cab had traded Kyrie Irving
for Chris Paul
if Kyrie Irving had made his feelings
known you know after the season and they
could have maybe tried to bring Chris
Paul in and instead of him going to
Houston and then maybe they could have
used Kevin Love and a separate trade to
do something else where was her Paul
George Jimmy Butler or somebody else is
that possible and again I can't say
that's a hypothetical what I can say is
Kyrie was frustrated after the season
but he never met with the Cavs - just to
tell them how frustrated he was could
that be because the guy he would have
gone to they they fired in David Griffin
that's one explanation for it he could
to be honest with you that's that's an
explanation I've been given but David
Griffin wasn't there and they still made
the trade demand I mean I if you really
wanted to man to trade I think you know
you can call the owner but what you just
said is an explanation that I have been
given not as I pathetical but has a
reason Brian went hoarse a couple more
minutes because there's so many more
things to talk about just based off of
these you know facts alone I want to
stick with the Paul George for a moment
it seems that the Pacers had better
offers but they were all from Eastern
Conference teams and that is what
trumped everything in their in their
conversations and strategy about trading
Paul George is that a fair assessment
Brian okay well here's what here's the
gray area if a team could have traded
for Paul George and knew that they were
going to appeal to keep him his value
was going to be stronger so if you're
the Pacers and you're talking with the
Cavs and they're offering Kevin Love
essentially it was going to be a
three-way trade with Denver where love
would get moved on to Denver but if if
you were talking with the Pacers and and
the Pacers actually thought that Paul
George was probably going to resign to
stay with LeBron the nay would have
wanted Kyrie Irving because trading Paul
George was one year on his contract has
certain value trading Paul George within
the division somebody did have to
compete with for long term is different
values and the Pacers felt that had they
sent him to Cleveland there was a good
chance he was going to extend and
with LeBron James so that made it
difficult to work out a trade because
the cab are making offers that it
we only might have them for one year so
on a one-year rental we're willing to
give X and and so that's why it's hard
to do this the other thing is this is
going to be important with Kyrie going
forward it's extraordinarily hard in the
NBA to complete three team trade I'm
already seeing people posting their
three team trade online like oh here's
the three team trade the Knicks get this
the heat get this the cab get this
Street a three team trade rich is a no
team trade a fourteen trade to the pipe
dream so obviously they happen but maybe
one out of a thousand three team trade
offers happen and that was a three team
trade offer it's really really hard but
be to get to the bottom line if the Cavs
knew the Kyrie Irving wanted to trade in
June and whether it was Kyrie position
or the Cavs position but they didn't
know that forget about that if they knew
Kyrie wanted a trade before the draft
this loss season would have looked
completely different for the entire NBA
because it would have changed the Paul
George situation it would have changed
him he Butler it might have changed
Chris Paul it might have changed or
Celtics a whole bunch of things so
having said that going forward we could
see a whole bunch of crazy things happen
including the Cavs making a trade and
I'm not saying this is likely but it's
possible the Cavs making a trade that
actually makes them more competitive
against the Warriors maybe not with a
player that's better than Tyree but
maybe with us with a team that's more
competitive and maybe this trade that
they're about to make keeps LeBron James
long term maybe it drives them away but
maybe it keeps them and that's why you
got to watch the NBA should I should I
should I check on my grandmother to see
if she has wheels to make her a wagon
Brian I mean should I do that now after
after hearing that last soliloquy right
there I I don't know I just
here's what I know about the NBA people
keep asking what LeBron is going to do
in next June like they all want an
answer I can't tell you what's good
to happen in the NBA by 3 p.m. it's
incredible I mean it's incredible and I
got the Commissioner on next hour he's
got to be ecstatic over this last one
for you Brian real quick if I gave you a
choice in a 2018-19 season not next
season but the year after that who is
more likely to be on the Cavs roster
Kyrie LeBron or neither what would you
choose Oh LeBron's more like because I
think Tyrese getting traded this year do
you think he gets traded this year or
next year I think I read gets traded
before training camp but that said the
Cavs don't feel any pressure to trade
him because even though Kyrie is unhappy
and Express he wants out and that's bad
news
the Cavs hold all the cards note he has
two years on his contract and he doesn't
have a no trade clause so the Cavs can
wait until February but I think I don't
think I real I think they're gonna trade
Brian
apologies to mrs. win horse to go have
that lunch thank you appreciating rich
it's Brian win horse the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy